The Surprising Truth About Cousins and Marriage
In modern western society, marrying your cousin
is not well accepted, particularly in the
United States.
Through a combination of old prejudices and
present-day conventional wisdom about inherited
birth defects, first cousin marriage is seen
by many as a little too close for comfort,
as well as a bad idea if you want children.
However, first cousin marriage is far more
common, and far less dangerous, than many
of us have been led to believe, as you’ll
soon see.
Further, if you include second cousins in
the mix, according to the Clinical Genetics
Handbook, the increased risks with regards
to having children are nearly non-existent
in this case compared with non-cousin marriage.
So where did the taboo against cousin marriage
start?
While there have been instances of the banning
of marriage between cousins at various points
through history, such as the Roman Catholics
banning the practice for a time starting with
the Council of Agde in 506 AD, for the most
part marriage among cousins has been popular
as long as people have been getting married.
In fact, it is estimated that as many as 80%
of the marriages in human history have been
between first or second cousins.
This switch in cousin-marriage’s acceptance
began in earnest in some parts of the Western
world in the mid-19th century.
Specifically, until the 1860s or so, first
cousins commonly married in Europe and the
U.S.
In fact, Charles Darwin, Mr. Natural Selection
himself, was married to his first cousin Emma
Wedgwood.
Nonetheless, the practice soon fell out of
fashion in the United States.
Although never outlawed in England, during
the second half of the 19th century, many
states began to ban marriages between first
cousins, as part of a larger movement after
the Civil War for greater state involvement
in a variety of areas, including education,
health and safety.
Researchers note that the distinction in marriage
bans between England and the U.S. may be explained
by the fact that, in the United States, the
practice “was associated not with the aristocracy
and upper middle class [Queen Victoria and
Prince Albert were second cousins] but with
much easier targets: immigrants and the rural
poor.”
Regardless, cousin marriage bans began popping
up across the states, with the first in Kansas
in 1858.
Ohio, New Hampshire, Nevada, North Dakota,
South Dakota, Washington and Wyoming banned
the practice in the 1860s, and many more had
enacted bans by the 1920s.
The most recent state to ban cousin marriage
was Texas in 2005.
Today, first cousin marriage is only allowed
without restriction in 19 states, and with
some restrictions in Arizona, Illinois, Indiana,
Maine, Utah, Wisconsin and North Carolina
(in North Carolina, while first cousins may
marry, “double cousins” may not- more
on this one in a bit.)
The distinction lies in the debate about whether
or not there is an increased risk that the
partners’ shared genes will produce an increased
chance that their offspring will have recessive,
undesirable traits.
A recent report on births in a British-Pakistani
community (where first cousin marriage is
very common) demonstrated that first cousin
children there were twice as likely to be
born with “potentially life threatening
birth defects” as compared with the children
of unrelated parents.
Advocates on the other side point out that
this resulted in only a 6% chance for the
children in the study, as compared with a
3% chance for the population as a whole.
For your reference, this increase in birth
defect rate is about the same as the increased
risk of a woman having a baby when she is
40 vs. when she is 30.
Proponents here point out that few would advocate
banning a 40 year old woman from having children.
They also point to recent testing that placed
the increased risk of spina bifida and cystic
fibrosis at only 1.7% to 2.8% higher than
for children of unrelated parents.
Further, researchers point out that “the
widely accepted scare stories – even within
academia – and the belief that cousin marriage
is inevitably harmful have declined in the
face of some of the data we’ve been producing.”
It should also be noted that some of the children
born with defects in the recent British study
may, in fact, have been double cousins (best
explained by an example):
“If a girl and her sister . . . meet two
brothers, they pair off . . and each couple
produces a baby . . . those kids [would be
double cousins]”
A community nurse who works among the Pakistani
community in the British study opined:
“A first cousin marries a first cousin and
the couple’s own grandparents are cousins,
too.
I have heard of first-cousin marriages going
back generation after generation in some families.”
This brings us to cross-cousins vs. parallel
cousins.
In some societies, first cousin marriage is
traditional and well-accepted, although many
make a distinction between “cross-cousins”
and “parallel cousins.”
Cross cousins have parents who are siblings,
but of the opposite sex.
The parents of parallel cousins are also siblings
but are of the same sex.
In cultures where cross cousins are encouraged
and parallel discouraged, it is often an inherited
taboo, passed down from when there was greater
inter-marriage and inter-mingling among the
members of an extended family – with a greater
chance that first cousins could also be half-siblings.
As noted in the book The Evolution of Sex,
“Fathers who are also brothers may overtly
or covertly share sexual relations with the
wife of one or the other . . . . Likewise,
mothers who are also sisters may overtly or
covertly share sexual access to the husband
of one or the other, raising the possibility
that apparent parallel cousins are actually
half-siblings, sired by the same father . . . .[With]
cross cousins, because in the absence of full-sibling
incest, it is unlikely [they] . . . can share
a father . . . [unless a] mother had a brother
whose wife was impregnated by [mother's husband].”
This is not very likely to happen in modern
societies that practice first-cousin marriage.
In fact, in a number of countries, including
the United Arab Emirates, Jordan, Yemen and
in the Palestinian Territories, paternal parallel
cousin marriage is the preferred form of consanguineous
marriage.
In the end, despite Western taboos today,
globally, cousin marriages are still going
strong, with an estimated 10% of all marriages
in the world being between cousins, and as
high as 50% in some regions of the world.
However, cousin marriage is making a comeback
in the U.S., as well, as more and more studies
continue to debunk the overblown risks once
commonly touted.
First cousins marrying in 21st century America
discover that many states no longer regulate
the practice, despite perhaps having laws
against it.
Likewise, most sects of Christianity do not
forbid it, which would be hard to do given
cases like Isaac and Rebekah in the Book of
Genesis.
For instance, the Methodist Church, has “no
official position on marriage between cousins.”
Nonetheless, it’s not easy being in a first
cousin marriage in some regions of the world.
As one man in such a relationship recently
discussed, some members of the couple’s
immediate family no longer speak to them and
have never met the couple’s children.
On top of that, he stated,
“We don’t typically tell folks.
We told our daughters, “It’s not something
to be ashamed of, but [don't] tell your friends
. . . people are fickle, and preteens and
teens can be downright cruel.”
Bonus Fact:
• Some famous individuals who married their
first cousins include: Albert Einstein (with
his second wife Elsa), H.G. Wells (with Isabel
Mary Wells), Saddam Hussein (with Sajida Talfah),
Christopher Robin Miln and his wife Leslie
(the former being of Winnie the Pooh fame),
and Edgar Allen Poe with Virginia Clemm, among
many, many more.
A recent famous example of a second cousin
marriage was between Rudy Giuliani and (his
now ex-wife) Regina Peruggi.